For this video, I’m going to show you how
to take a handful of rubber bands, and make
the worlds simplest, semi-automatic, rubber
band handgun.
I found this cool rubber band shooter at a
sporting goods store, but it comes with a
heavy price tag. $16 for the gun, and another
$2 for the bag of bands to go with it. We
can do better than that, so save your money
and let’s make a super simple version, for
free. Chances are, you already have two of
them on hand.
To start, you’ll need a bag of assorted
rubber bands like these. The colored ones
are a bit more fun, and you can usually find
them at the dollar stores.
Now to stalk up on the best rounds of ammunition,
try picking out the thicker bands that are
as wide as three fingers held together.
When you're to ready load your weapon, simply
hold one end of the bands with your pinky
finger, then stretch it all the way back,
and around behind your thumb, so you can position
the other end on the tip of your pointer finger.
Your elastic handgun is loaded, and ready
to fire.
Use your pointer finger to aim at the target,
then simply open your pinky finger to fire the shot off.
Now check this out we still have 2 more fingers,
and that means we can take this idea, to the next level.
Start by loading a rubber band the same way
you did before, then put 2 more rounds in
the chamber with a second and third band,
on your fourth and middle fingers.
You’ve just upgraded your weapon to semi-automatic.
With this setup you can fire at multiple targets
without having to stop and reload after each
shot. And with some practice, your aim can
get impressively accurate.
Now with a slight variation in your shooting
technique, you can easily switch from semi-automatic,
to shotgun blast. Simply release all your
fingers at the same time to send all the rounds
flying at once. This method spreads the ammo
out, so you can hit small targets from a distance,
or pump more power into targets at close range.
Well now you know how to use spare rubber
bands, to make a semi-automatic, elastic blasting
handgun. So go ahead, and have all the same
rubber shooting fun, while enjoying the savings,
of your 5 finger discount.
Well that’s it for now. If you like this
video, perhaps you’ll like some
of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com